bonsoir leçon peut-il briser les
inégalités sociales
le son est à l'origine de la création du
monde du big bang
le son est à l'origine de la musique le
son est à l'origine du langage mais le
son est également à l'origine des
apprentissages déjà in utero ma mère est
autrichienne
mon père et pieds-noirs deux continents
qui salit des contrastes des langues et
des sons variés
en grandissant j'ai compris que le
multiculturalisme était une chance et
que la diversité la différence c'était
une richesse quand j'ai eu mes enfants
quand j'ai eu mes enfants j'ai compris
j'ai vu aussi les défis devant lesquels
il allait être en l'occurrence le monde
se globalise et dans 20 ans nos enfants
devront être plus à l'aise dans le monde
international que nous aujourd'hui et ça
commence dès le berceau
je pense qu'il faudra être encore plus
dans l' écoute l'écoutent de l'autre
l'écoutent de soi l'ouverture à l'autre
la communication et cela passe par le
langage
mais devant le langage il y a déjà des
inégalités devant les apprentissages à
l'entrée en primaire il ya déjà beaucoup
de contrastes chez les enfants certains
vont très bien parler et d'autres
n'auront passé de vocabulaire pour
comprendre leurs interlocuteurs certains
n'arriveront pas à se concentrer
alors est-ce que l'inégalité est une
fatalité
je ne crois pas je crois que chacun peut
contribuer à rendre ce monde meilleur
pour ma part ma petite pierre à
l'édifice s'est fait en créant des
crèches avec un outil que j'ai inventé
la bulle musicale
c'est un outil multi sensorielle
interactif
qui permet aux enfants de découvrir la
multiplicité sonores et de voyager en
musique
nous accueillons trois cent cinquante
enfants parents et c'est 350 enfants
aujourd'hui nous avons la preuve
scientifique de l'impact de la richesse
sonore et de l'exposition au
multiculturalisme
dès le plus jeune âge et ça leur impact
sur leur apprentissage
l'apprentissage de ces tout petits alors
ils ont un mois trois ans à la sortie de
la crèche
ils auront déjà fait trois fois le tour
du monde
oui vous avez bien entendu ils vont
profiter d'un jeu exploratoire adaptés à
leur âge qui leur permettra de voyager
peut-être plus que vous et moi durant
toute notre vie alors un mois trois ans
ça peut vous paraître jeune très jeune
trop jeune peut-être
et pourtant tellement de choses
commencent déjà in utero à cette semaine
de grossesse
les premières les premières sensations
de l'enfant in utero se font grâce aux
vibrations du son qui pénètre au travers
de la paroi abdominale et qui vont sur
le bassin de la maman et qui touche le
petit crâne en formation à cinq mois de
grossesse
le système auditif de l'enfant est déjà
mature et il se rajoute à ce système
l'enfant in utero quand il ne dort pas
il passe son temps à écouter
louis est le premier et le seul sens qui
le relie directement au monde au monde
extérieur au monde intérieur au monde
intérieur bien sûr de sa maman avec le
battement du coeur avec le bruit de la
circulation sanguine avec les bruits
d'indigestion avec la voie de la maman
mais aussi aux bruits extérieurs
les voix les voies du papa de
l'entourage les musiques tout ça ça
constitue des rythmes et des mélodies
avec ses sons ça constitue une mélodie
et donc c'est la première musique
alors ce soir je vous propose de
replonger dans ce qui a été votre
environnement sonore pendant neuf mois
[Musique]
c'était vos premières émotions donc
cessons sont d'une certaine façon connue
ce que l'on sait un petit peu moins
c'est que l'an quand l'enfant né il a
une capacité auditive total qui lui
permet d'entendre tous les sons de
toutes les langues du monde entier à
quatre mois il entendra il discernera
des sons un accent indie que ni vous ni
moi ne percevront à six mois il
gazouille est ce qu'à votre avis les
gazouillis d'un enfant français chinois
algériens sont les mêmes écoutez bien
vous allez être surpris
[Musique]
pourquoi ce sont ces gazouillis sont-ils
si différents
chaque langue dispose d'une bande de
fréquences sonores à partir de 9 mois
dix mois louis est le cerveau de
l'enfant vont se concentrer sur
l'environnement sonore qui est propre à
la langue maternelle louis est le seul
sens qui se développe à l'envers c'est à
dire qu'ils diminuent
d'ailleurs à partir de 7 ans un enfant
apprendra une langue étrangère mais avec
l'accent de sa langue maternelle
si les enfants si les français ne sont
pas si douée que ça semble-t-il pour
apprendre les langues étrangères ou
peut-être un peu moins que les allemands
ou les slaves
c'est une question d'oreille
c'est parce que la bande du français est
étroite et dix coups du coup la capacité
auditive du français sous concentre sur
cet environnement
donc c'est une question physiologique
d'abord aujourd'hui il fallait quelque
chose de nouveau et cette chose nouvelle
eh ben c'est justement la bulle musicale
dont je vais vous parler cette bulle
musicale
c'est un outil multi sensorielle
interactif qui se centre sur les enfants
qui implique les parents et l'équipe
elle s'inscrit dans un projet global qui
met le son et la musique au centre par
petites touches de façon exclusivement
ludique pour les enfants de la crèche et
en permettant à ses enfants d'être
toujours acteurs de leur découverte
c'est un igloo de 9 mètres carrés dans
lequel il y a des touches et les enfants
rentrent et il touche
c'est ces capteurs qui déclenche des
sons d'animaux de langue des ambiances
sonores des comptines des rythmes et des
musiques toutes sortes de musique salsa
du jazz la musique classique jusqu'à la
musique traditionnelle chinoise par
exemple alors ce soir je vais vous
emmener dans la bulle musicale avec moi
et participer à un voyage que les
enfants découvrent pendant un mois
chacun dans la crèche et je vais vous
partager trois histoires qui m'ont
marqué sarah sahara à deux ans nous
sommes en voyage en inde et l aime
beaucoup les foulards colorés elle aime
découvrir les photos des éléphants qui
sont habillés de parure de fête
mais ce qu elle même par dessus tout
cette année dans la bulle et puis touché
ces capteurs qui déclenche des sons
autour de la langue du tamoul et un beau
jour quelques jours plus tard elle
ressort de la bulle et en récitant en
chantant elle compte en tamoul toute
seule elle a appris dans la bulle alors
les auxiliaires sont assez estomaqué
donc là regardez bien sûr elle est
encore plus fier est elle répète cette
découverte
elle a beaucoup de joie dans cette
martin à 18 mois un petit bonhomme je
suis dans la bulle avec d'autres adultes
mais il rentre y pénètrent et il a pas
peur il connaît père elle connaît pas
les autres personnes et puis il nous
fait signe qu'il a pas envie de rester
en chine là où nous sommes actuellement
il envie d'écouter pan pan pan pan
qu'est ce que c'est panpan non c'est
parce que vous croyez
panpan c'est la flûte de pan il va aller
au pérou alors nous repartons au pérou
et nous remettons la banque de sons qui
1,50 son est très vite ils découvrent ce
son qui est magique pour lui alors à ce
moment là du haut de ses dix-huit mois
ils nous regardaient effet nous demande
de nous taire pour mieux se concentrer
pour écouter ce son qui génère une
formidable émotion à lui le papa de
kevin rentrer dans la bulle l'équipe a
réussi à convaincre le papa de kevin de
venir jouer de la darbouka le papa de
kevin jouer de la darbouka au bled
mais depuis qu'il est arrivé en france
il a dû mettre de côté beaucoup de
choses qui le concerne son enfance son
histoire sa culture il faut s'intégrer
alors il s'assied au centre de la bulle
devant le groupe d'enfants dont son
petit garçon kevin hill et en costume
cravate
il prend le dard boukai lemay entre ses
jambes et il commence à jouer dans un
premier temps il est un peu intimidé il
joue doucement et puis petit à petit
c'est doit retrouvent leur agilité et le
rythme vient et en face les enfants
répondent immédiatement et commence à se
dandiner commence à danser alors de papa
de kevin sans gaillard 10 mai kevin lui
ne bouge pas il est là et regarde son
papa il a les yeux écarquillés son papa
voit que son fils leurs gardes alors il
continue à jouer encore de plus belle
mais petit kevin ne bouge pas et puis
soudain il se redresse
il se lève plein de fierté c'est son
papa qui joue
dans ce moment là le petit kevin a
découvert une facette de son papa qu'il
ne connaissait pas et son papa à
reconnecter avec ses souvenirs d'enfance
et ils ont partagé un merveilleux moment
de complicité des histoires comme ça il
y en a beaucoup et des retours
enthousiastes des parents ces retours
enthousiastes m'ont conduit à lancer une
recherche avec des chercheurs
scientifiques en psycholinguistique est
en lien avec l'inserm pour comprendre ce
qui se passe et les résultats sont très
significatifs les enfants qui ont reçu
qui ont participé à ce programme autour
de la bulle musicale dispose d'un
vocabulaire qui est presque le double à
la moyenne nationale
quel que soit le milieu
quel que soit l'environnement familial
ils ont plus de 70% de vocabulaire donc
une chance de plus pour réussir dès la
primaire donc ma conclusion c'est plus
l'enfant entend jeunes des sons plus il
entend des musiques plus lille entend
des mots plus il renforce son
développement cognitif déjà ses
capacités langagières mais aussi sa
concentration sa mémoire
même ses compétences mathématiques et
avec le développement du plaisir de lait
coûte aujourd'hui avec dix ans de recul
je suis fier de pouvoir contribuer à
donner à ses enfants les mêmes chances
de réussir et de cette bulle qui est un
outil multi sensorielle c'est aussi un
outil de lutte contre les inégalités
sociales
quel que soit l'environnement familial
ou social
alors si le son et la musique sont aussi
importants boost l'intelligence alors
donnons leur un rôle majeur dès la
crèche et à l'école afin que cela
devienne un standard et non une
exception oui le son peut briser le mur
des inégalités merci
[Musique]